a day in gotham city is rarely
injury-free broken bones bruises
covering half a person's face and
injuries sustained by a whip made for
brutal days on set and we've got 15 of
the worst incidents coming right up
there is an element of fear
number one
this nasty injury came right out of the
gate robert pattinson was hardly even
used to the fact that he was batman
before a stunt brought him down i broke
my wrist at the beginning of it all
doing a stunt even before covet needing
time to recover at that point worked out
pretty well since so soon after kovid
did shut the production down giving the
actor plenty of time to properly recover
in retrospect pattinson realized how
intense it all felt at the time i
remember when that seemed like the worst
thing that could go wrong with a start
like this it's no wonder that by the end
he was really really really dead
afterward
number two
no pain no gain right
maybe that's what the riddler actor was
thinking when he came up with what
seemed like a good plan i thought well
i'll wrap myself in some cling film and
see if that will cover up any uh dna
evidence the actor was obviously
struggling with director matt reeves
saying he looked like a beat after
revealing what was going on under the
mask my head was throbbing and the sweat
couldn't escape from my body this was
just his first full day on set it was
hard to like come down sometimes the
costume department wound up making some
adjustments so the actor could work more
easily but the struggles didn't stop
there as the actor carried a bit of
trauma with him after the fact i
probably didn't sleep as well as i would
have liked on some nights because it was
a little difficult to come down from
this character but it all uh hopefully
fueled the fire
number three tough guys can take a
beating every now and then right and she
punches hard i forgot about that zoe
kravitz had to keep her energy up for
her action sequences in the film so
between takes she'd often beat on a
punching bag there was also another time
when you were punching me in between
except for that time that she used rob
as a punching bag instead her reasoning
was pretty fair it's because we were
starting in the middle of a fight
fortunately pattinson didn't have it as
bad as another cast member that kravitz
did some serious damage to hit i hit
someone in the face like that
yikes this catwoman has some serious
claws you're fine you're batman
number four
when will the cowl struggles end
even after so many brilliant actors have
played batman the helmet portion of the
suit still causes endless suffering to
the caped crusaders that was the one
that was very very tight on my ears as
if that and the fact that he couldn't
really see wasn't enough pattinson was
also hooked up with an earpiece that he
couldn't remove himself it was a decent
idea as matt reeves was able to give the
actor clear directions when in the bat
suit but every now and then all the
walkie-talkies would wind up on the same
channel and pattinson would get a big
convoluted and very loud earful
trying to do a scene
number five this actor had a right to be
nervous
colin farrell looks tough as can be as
the penguin but racing down the street
in a speeding car was a definite cause
for alarm the actor was pretty honest
about his feelings surrounding filming
the stunt i was scared a terrified man
because i was being thrown all over the
place and they had a driver on the roof
of the car i wasn't even in control he
wasn't in control of the car at all and
had to deal with being bumped
erratically around the whole time it was
far from an easy shoot but it made the
whole acting scared portion a total
breeze
number six
you gotta work with what you've got and
in this case it was a bit of a match
made in heaven andy circus as alfred was
pretty perfect casting for a few reasons
one of them being the fact that director
matt reeves had written in a cane for
the character it made sense in the story
and when circus found out he was all in
actually
broken my left hip so it actually kind
of worked in my favor that i had a cane
now that was meant to be
number seven
sometimes the pain just doesn't quit zoe
kravitz came out of filming the batman
fairly unscathed but that's because her
training pushed her over the edge
leaving her seriously struggling mostly
i just went home in a lot of pain every
day the intense training and the fact
that she was doing it non-stop left her
with a whole lot of wear and tear that
carried into her day to day hobbling
down the stairs on top of that there
were her claws they help you in in in
the film in life they make your life
very difficult they caused her a lot of
grief and concern i couldn't open things
it was really scary washing my face at
night
goes to show the length actors will go
number eight
if you're gonna be punched by anyone it
might as well be someone super cool
someone like say the caped crusader uh
if you gotta take a punch i guess you
take one from batman you know jeffrey
wright was a champ when his character
james gordon got a beating from patton
since batman but in the long run the
damage might have been worse than
initially thought i'm still recovering a
little bit as you can clearly hear from
my answers today that's just the price
you pay to say you were punched by
batman
number nine
it wasn't a pretty sight filming for the
2022 movie the flash was intense with
one of the scarier days being when there
was a full crash on set one crew member
was pulling double duty as a stunt and
camera person riding a motorcycle behind
the bat cycle to capture all the action
unfortunately during one take the crew
member lost control and ran right into
the back of the bat cycle getting
tangled up and dragged by it considering
how fast they were going it took some
time to slow down and actually come to a
proper stop so the stuntman could be
taken care of it was a terrifying moment
but fortunately the cameraman didn't
suffer any intense injuries and was able
to get back to work a little bit later
that day
number 10 playing batman at an older age
comes with its risks ben affleck
suffered a nasty shoulder strain filming
batman vs superman dawn of justice the
actor did continue working but his
injury was showing as he was favoring
his left side on camera until he just
couldn't carry out all the action
himself
his stunt double took over when there
was more heavy lifting to do like
casually and swiftly picking up a child
number 11.
these boys got a bit carried away when
heath ledger and christian bale filmed
their first scene in the dark knight
together there was no holding back in
part because of just how committed
ledger was to the part bale was a bit
hesitant with just how hard he was
beating on his co-star but heath was
there for it even pushing him to go
further with it so the scene would be
authentic if bale showed any hesitation
ledger was in his face taunting him to
go on go on go on
number 12. we know by now the cowl is
always a tough one for batman's
christian bale was nearly passing out
performing in his bat suit one day on
set was particularly chilly and the cold
weather meant the cowl of the bat suit
would get tighter than usual and much
tighter than desirable the restriction
became so intense it caused bale to gasp
rare and start seeing stars in the
moment bale knew he had to escape the
suit and urgently sought help before he
was unconscious
number 13
this cat can scratch ann hathaway got a
little too into character and with a gun
in hand well it made her a major danger
a stunt performer she was duking it out
with saw the butt of a gun jammed into
their eye socket causing an almost
instantaneous black eye and half bruised
face the performer was a good sport
about the ordeal but hathaway was
understandably pretty mortified and
wanted to make up for it a bit somehow
that stunt performer is now the owner of
a special silver pin hathaway had made
saying remember no one packs a punch
like anne
number 14. it's a bird it's a plane it's
a crashing parachutist one night a man
in scotland was watching on as some
high-flying stunts were being filmed
nearby for the dark knight rises until
things took a turn and a parachutist
crashed into the roof of a house right
next to him considering where they were
filming it's not too surprising there
were intense wind conditions that
ultimately caused the parachutist to
lose control and crashed through the sky
with nothing but a roof to break his
landing the accident was so brutal that
it could have been a fatal one but
luckily the performer only suffered a
few injuries
number 15. michelle pfeiffer's catwoman
was a wild one filming batman returns
saw the actress whipping around a
10-foot bull whip pfeiffer accidentally
cut her own face while she was training
but this didn't deter her from wanting
to carry out her stunts so she covered
up her injuries with makeup to hide the
truth from the production team who she
worried would make her stop for safety
the damage of the whip didn't stop there
though pfeiffer's whipmaster found
himself in the direct line of danger the
actress admitting i slashed his face and
drew blood despite the bloodshed and
injuries suffered the actress was a big
fan of using the whip feeling it was a
beautiful weapon
it hurts but oftentimes it works the
injuries are never fun but they come
with the territory of doing such intense
and action-packed films
whose injury do you think was most
brutal